this is something that anyone needs to
sit down for if you're not already
sitting down the 49ers have narrowed
their universe of potential quarterback
selections at number three to two guys
mac jones trey lance i i think it's
always been narrowed to one i don't get
this is this part of some broader effort
to ensure that the first three picks in
the draft aren't all known going into
thursday night we already know the first
two i still don't buy the idea that your
guy kyle traded all that stuff to go to
number three and didn't know who the
hell he was taking chris i i mean listen
i'm with you i don't know what else to
say i i would think that yes he knew who
he was going to take but the fact that
we're here this far from the draft
and
that we still
are having this conversation
i mean where there's smoke there's fire
i have a hard time believing that trey
lance isn't truly a part of the equation
you know and then maybe we need to just
go back to like what john lynch said at
that press conference right right after
they made the trade
we liked the quarterbacks in this draft
so maybe they weren't lying maybe they
were legitimately like hey wait we like
all three so we're willing to get up
here and we're gonna as we were saying
back then take fate into our own hands
yeah i would think shanahan has one guy
he likes for sure i would but they
continue to do their due diligence i
don't know if a trey lance grew on him
or whatever else i don't have the
answers to that but i think at this
point the fact that we hear these rumors
all weekend i think is
i i think it's a safe assumption to say
no that we wouldn't be still hearing
this if it was just lock stock two
smoking barrels it's mac jones there
must be some dialogue still in that
49ers organization on what to do here at
the number three pick
and the the
the sub headline to this is that justin
fields is now out of the mix so they
have at least scratched one name off if
that name was ever even on the list in
the first place they did go to his pro
day two they went to trey lance's pro
day two they went to mac jones pro day
two so many of these quarterbacks having
two pro days this year because they
couldn't do private workouts so that
opportunity to get to know a guy well
off the grid that just wasn't there
let me throw something at you because
look ideally
in these nfl headquarters everyone's
always on the same page there's no
ulterior motive
there's no
separate agenda
is it possible
that kyle
is and always has been and always will
be
team mac jones
but there's a little cya going on
i told you so trying to build a little i
told you so with lynch getting behind
trey lance
and if lance ends up being great and
jones ends up crapping the bed for some
reason i almost said the other word
there which would not have been amazing
yeah that would have been awesome that
would have been great
but
could it be
could it be that john lynch is playing a
little bit of a political game here and
staking out some trade lance territory
in the event that lance is great and
jones stinks and he picks up
some
some estimation some esteem some cred in
the eyes of jed york the owner of the
team do you think that could be going on
mike i don't
i don't know if it's exactly that
i do get the sense and and because i
hear this from other people in the
league yeah there's people in the front
office
that love trey lance there in san
francisco there's no doubt about it i've
heard it from from multiple people so i
don't know if it's you know john lynch
trying to play a political game you know
i've heard one of their you know top
personnel guys i'm one of them i
butcher the name here adam is it adam
peters adam peters yeah adam peters
right
there's the rumor around the nfl that
he's in love with trey lance you talk to
anybody kind of in the know that's what
you hear
so
there's obviously people in the
organization in his camp there's no
doubt about that you know added to
listen i have a hard time sitting here
on a monday right before the draft too
thinking that you know the way it looks
to me here on the outside looking in
that you know shanahan's not he's
feeling the pressure of this pick i mean
people are ready to jump off the golden
gate bridge when they heard mack jones
might be the number three pick so i do
wonder if the pressure's getting to him
a little bit i mean really we we it
looked like we were gonna like have like
you know
uh
marches in the street that mac jones was
number three so many people were mad
there so there's that but it's it's
interesting nonetheless nonetheless and
listen i don't think a report comes out
like this because i like you said mike
there's no benefit for the 49ers to have
this report out to be like
what are they like playing favorites
with trey lance agent or anything like
you know what i mean there's no there's
no reason so i i think at base level we
need to take it for what it is and that
there might be a possibility here that
it's not mac jones and maybe trey lance
is more in this conversation than i
would have ever thought
i mean we could go ultra next level and
suggest that kyle shanahan is trying to
dupe one of his former employers into
taking trey lance right at number four
the falcons but i i i that i know right
yeah there's no benefit to him right
cares what the falcons do yeah so that's
where i get i get into a little mic of
just like
you know
it's interesting hey the public pressure
you know i'm a mac jones fan trey lance
has an interesting skill set as we've
talked about the way he can run his arm
is very powerful it's gifted it's just
inconsistent i think you've heard me say
that too
but it's going to be two different
offenses too that's where i look at it
and go whoa that could be intriguing
listen i think mac jones could be like
drew brees or or matt ryan in the
shanahan offense
trey lance
i don't we got a taste of that rg3
offense a few years ago right down in
washington maybe shanahan's toying with
that in his brain saying let's do that
let's see what i got with that run game
i got and now you add trey lance to the
run game too
so
i don't have an answer for you but that
would be the logic i would use is just
sitting here as a guy that follows
football in the 49ers
let me rewind to october of 2017 when
the 49ers traded for jimmy garoppolo
that was between
when they didn't take a close look at
the quarterbacks available in the 2017
draft because kyle shanahan and he has
since essentially confirmed that he
thought he was getting kirk cousins in
free agency the next year
what happened in the organization to get
kyle to back away from waiting for
cousins and accept garoppolo because
there were stories at the time yeah he
wasn't happy about it and we've always
thought he's in charge there well
somebody pulled
the trump card on him right and traded
for jimmy g and it makes me wonder to
the extent that those forces were
successful then are those forces being
activated now on trey lance that's
what's that's what's fascinating to me
about this i almost feel like he's being
ganged up on between adam peters john
lynch maybe jed york maybe paraguarante
i don't know but i almost feel like
there's this this effort to get him
to just forget about mac jones let's
keep jimmy g for a year let's get trey
lance ready he's going to be even better
long-term than mac jones i know you want
to flip the switch now right to somebody
else let's do it this way let's give
garoppolo one year let's go to trey
lance in 2022 we're going to be a lot
better off because lance has a higher
ceiling i feel like someone's pushing
him and pushing him to do that i i mike
i i feel the same way you know that's
kind of what i was saying before it just
seems like that you know this this keeps
percolating
over the last five six days
and you just seem to continue to hear
this rumor of treyland's traylands tray
lance
so
uh
obviously there's somebody there and
then even some people who have talked
about it you know in the media
where i'm not gonna name names but i
know they know people in san francisco
so that makes me think like oh that came
i'm not saying it from kyle but that
came from i know he talks to somebody in
san francisco like there's just been too
many things there where i can connect
dots for me not to think it's it's
somewhat real here you know i i
i think
i think the the other thing i'll say to
just what you said right there mike if
they draft trey lance
i still want to say yeah he's raw but so
what play them play them this is the
problem with trey lance it's like i
don't know if i want to sit him for a
year because he sat last year and he
didn't get to throw the ball about a ton
just a year a ton of the year before so
i'm more of the guy like hey you pick
him in number three try to get get rid
of jimmy garoppolo you can run the ball
and through the run make the pass game
easier for a guy like trey lance and see
where it goes from there but i mean
again i'd be shocked if that's the way
it goes i really would i just thought
for sure we'd be seeing mac jones at
number three and we'd see something like
that matt ryan atlanta falcons offense
that we saw in 2016. so
this is big news something to follow
here
this is the problem with having options
because at some point you got to pick a
line you have to select a door and that
means you are going to the bigger of an
uncertainty it is you are going to have
to say well there goes the other guy and
he may end up becoming a hall of famer
with someone else and we may have picked
the wrong one
that that has happened from time to time
where teams face that either or
and
it either works
or it doesn't
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports